boss will be telling us very shortly
that if labor was in power there would
be a council tax freeze at the moment
why doesn't labor councils freeze their
council tax now
so what the government have done is that
they're forced on councils these council
tax increases to make up for the cuts in
funding from the central government and
it means that if nothing happens now
council tax is going to go up on average
by five percent on Saturday we're saying
there is another way and what we would
do if we were in government today would
be to extend the windfall tax on the
huge profits that the oil and gas giants
are making and use that money to freeze
council tax for a year because you'll
know okay your viewers will know that we
are right in the middle of a cost of
living crisis the most recent numbers
showed inflation going up again in
February we've got gas and electricity
bills twice where they were a year ago
Foods price inflation at a record high
and the Tory mortgage premium still from
the conservatives mini budget last year
means that people are looking to
remortgage this year are paying 2 000
pounds more on average that's why we're
saying let's not add insult to injury by
increasing council tax too
yeah but this went full tax that you
keep telling us about that you would
Implement you're going to use it to give
pay Rises to NHS staff and also to help
soften the blow with these further
increases in energy bills how far is it
going to go
well I've been calling as you know okay
for a windfall tax since January 2022
the government came up with a pale
imitation their energy profits Levy but
it had so many holes in it it means
companies like shell didn't even pay a
penny of that tax last year so we're
calling on the government to extend that
tax to back date it from when the win
for profit started to come in to close
the loopholes and set that tax rate at
the same level that Norway sets theirs
that could raise over uh this year and
next around 10 billion pounds more than
the government are currently getting uh
in they've left that money on the table
the council tax changes we're announcing
today cost 2.7 billion pounds we're
saying that that windfall tax money
should be used to freeze council tax and
give people some relief with their bills
yeah but this winter fall tax is 10
billion that you're talking about you
also wanted to use that to soften the
blow on the increases
um in energy bills and also to pay for
increases uh in salary for NHS workers
how much would all of that cost
well we previously said that it should
be used to help with gas electricity
bills in the budget the government did
announce some support for gas and
electricity bills but they're still
leaving there's 10 billion pounds on the
table it's still there it still hasn't
been taxed it still hasn't been spent
and so we're saying the government
should use it now to help people with
their gas and electricity bills this
policy would cost 2.7 billion pounds
this year and the windfall tax would
raise over 10 billion pounds so this is
a fully costed a fully funded uh policy
I've always been really clear okay I'm
not going to make any spending
commitments or any commitments to cut
taxes without saying where that money is
going to come from that is really
important the Tories crashed the economy
last year by making unfunded uh tax cuts
undetermined that labor won't fall into
those same traps so this is a fully
costed a fully funded policy but most
crucially it will make a massive
difference to people who are struggling
with all those Rising prices rising
bills Rising prices rising taxes and
we're saying that we would help by
freezing council tax bill a big monthly
cost to families up and down the country
you've also previously said that the
windfall tax would be used to pay for
Rises for NHS staff such as Junior
doctors how much would that cost
we've never said that okay what we have
said previously is that the money could
be used to help people with their gas
and electricity bills but the government
still haven't used that money it is
still there on the table gas and
electricity bills after we called for
them to be frozen they have now been
frozen from April we're saying the
government now can use this money that
is still there that still hasn't been
taxed increase that tax on those
windfall profits and use it to freeze
council tax bills
um do you support keeping the state
pension at the age where it is at the
moment or should it be increased to 68.
so I'm just having some problems with
the wind uh here okay I'm on the state
pension Aid that I'm pleased that the
government have made the decision that
they have today to postpone any further
increases in the state pension age
because the most recent uh figures on on
life expectancy show that after
increasing for decades and decades life
expectancy has now stalled so this would
be the wrong time to further increase
the state pension age
um we want to see the government do more
to help people in their 50s and their
60s people with disabilities back into
work but we don't think that any further
increase in the state pension age is the
way to do that I'm gonna have to let you
go because I know you're going to get on
a train to Swindon don't you so that you
can be with the bosses local election
campaigns yeah it's good to see you as
always